the nice guys is written and directed by
Shane black and stars Russell Crowe and
Ryan Gosling and is a story of two
private detectives who are looking for a
girl named Amelia who in some weird way
is involved with the death of a porn
star who in some weird way is involved
with the death of someone else who in
some weird ways involved the death of
someone else and it's 1977 basically the
movie is these two guys getting to know
each other Russell Crowe plays a tough
guy he's the kind of guy you hire to
maybe beat somebody up who's following
you he's not actually a private
detective but he kind of wishes he was
he fancies himself a P I Ryan Gosling
actually is the funny thing is Russell
Crowe's character is probably better at
his job even though he's not officially
licensed I was super excited for this
movie because Shane Black has written a
very small amount of films and although
I didn't love Iron Man 3 I enjoyed it I
did however adore Kiss Kiss Bang Bang
which is a very underrated movie with
Downey jr. and Val Kilmer that's a very
similar film as the nice guys and you
can tell that Shane black definitely
understands where he's at home writing
buddy cop movies like lethal weapon
because the nice guys just might be the
best movie I've seen so far this year
this is a fresh offbeat unconventional
original witty comedy with two actors at
the top of their game Russell Crowe and
Ryan Gosling in this film work magic
together these guys have amazing
chemistry and not just because they're
funny and they play off each other well
but also because these characters feel
at home with each other and yes that is
the classic buddy-cop genre thing you
pair Chris Tucker and Jackie Chan oh
that's strange you pair Mel Gibson and
Danny Glover huh those are two different
opposing people the difference here with
these characters is that they're not
actually that opposing they both have
troubled pasts they both have issues
with alcohol they're very similar in a
lot of ways they don't highly contrast
one another it's the fact that they work
together so well as a comedy team
playing off of each other that's so
fresh and original because usually these
movies are just about the fact that two
very different people suddenly after
work together but in this film it's sort
of like they're just like hey look we
understand the game we get how this town
works let's just see if we can make some
money
off of it and they're like yeah okay
whatever let's do it and I can't talk
enough about Shane Black's riding in
this movie it is on point scene to scene
consistently I was laughing out loud
full-on belly laughter screeching
laughter possibly annoying people around
me laughter which is rare for me this
movie is filled with so many lines that
are seared into my memory things that
just hit home so hard for me that just
burned into my consciousness that I'm
never going to forget there isn't that
dumb obvious scene where they Pat each
other on the back and say you know what
you're a pretty good man thanks you too
buddy let's walk off into the sunset the
action also great really great shootouts
old 1980 style action filmmaking despite
the fact that it takes place in the 70s
which I must say is perfectly realize I
feel like I just watched a film that
came out in the 70s just with better
film stock it's that good guys it's a
perfect recapturing of a setting the
mystery is appealing that dialogue is
great the characters are great
especially Ryan Gosling's little
daughter who much to goslings opposition
is kind of like the sidekick of their
various missions they go on and she's
amazing I mean so good
his daughter plays that kind of role
where she says adult things and you're
like oh it's cute and you know it's
funny but she it's not cute she just
sells it it feels so authentic this felt
like the type of movie that wouldn't
come out today like it's just past its
time Hollywood doesn't make movies like
this anymore these weird private
detective movies that are also very
funny it's just those don't exist
anymore guys we're not gonna make those
we need more special effects we need
more explosions we need CGI but this
movie is that type of movie it felt like
a present like a gift like hey we
understand that you have to watch a lot
of here's something great that
might remind you why you love movies so
much similar to Kiss Kiss Bang Bang
there's also a slight fantastical vibe
towards the final reel I couldn't get
enough of it good characters good
dialogue good story great direction the
nice guys is probably the best film I've
seen so far this year and I'm gonna give
it an
a-plus if you appreciate film as an
artform and you want film to be
preserved as an artform not just as a
business that can make money please go
see the nice guys this weekend it's one
of the better original films I've seen
in years also I do want to let you know
that my promotion with audible is still
running if you go to audible.com slash
Chris you can get a free 30-day trial of
their service they have tons and tons
hundreds of thousands quite literally of
audiobooks available for download
I love the website a lot of you guys
have told me that you've appreciated the
service as well some people have
downloaded it for school books so like I
said audible.com slash Chris for a free
30-day trial of audible check it out
guys there are so many awesome books at
your disposal if you like reading or if
you like listening to books when you're
working well like I do guys thank you so
much as always for watching please see
nice guys this weekend it really is
really that good and I really suggest
that you guys check it out and support
an original film which is rare nowadays
thanks so much guys for watching and if
you like this you can click right here
and get stuck mine eyes
[Music]
[Applause]